- C'est le père Noël, Sam. C'est
lui qui apporte les cadeaux.
- Les enfants demandent
des cadeaux sans trop se soucier
de l'inflation.
- Qu'est-ce que tu as demandé
au père Noël, toi?
- Pat'Patrouille.
- Une maison de poupées.
- Je veux des cadeaux.
- Les parents feront de leur
mieux.
- Je travaille le jour.
Je commence mes vacances
aujourd'hui. La pression, là,
c'est aujourd'hui et demain.
- C'est le dernier sprint
pour les emplettes des Fêtes.
- Ça, c'est les derniers qu
restaient. Le dernier argent
qui restait.
(rires)
- À trois jours de Noël,
les rabais de 50 % eplplus
nous rappellent presque
le Boxing Day. Les affaires
tournent au ralenti pour
ce bijoutier.
RARARARD SALOMON, propriétaire,
Bijouterie Adiel
- 50 %, parce que ça a commencé
très lentement. Donc, on a...
Je pense que je suis pas
le seul, mais beaucoup de
commerçants ont déjà commencé
à faire des promotions.
MICHEL ROCHETTE, prés., Conseil
canadien du commerce de détail
- On a vu ça venir, donc
des achats beaucoup plus tôt
dans l'année, une plus longue
période de magasinage, donc
les gens recherchent des rabais.
- Plus d'un Canadien sur deux
planifie réduire ses dépenses
pendant la période des Fêtes,
qui chuteront de 17 %
cette année pour atteindre
1520 $ par ménage.
Inflation, coût des aliments
et problèmes économiques
forcent les Canadiens
à se serrer la cererere.
- On va souvent au Dollarama.
Ils ont des bonnes choses,
puis c'est pas cher.
- Les commerçants, eux,
n'ont pas bénéficié des recettes
espérées du Vendredi fou
et du Cyberlundi.
- Mais comme les gens prenaient
e e e e temps cette année pour
réfléchir, donc c'est pas autant
d'achats qu'on aurait souhaité
cette année pendant ces deux
jours-là.
- Il faut donc offrir des rabais
plus alléchants.
FATIMA MOHAMMEDI,
représentante en ventes, Fido
- Parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de concurrence, ça fait
qu'il faut jouer beaucoup avec
les prix. T'sais, tu peux voir
une chute même la journée même.
JOSE CASTRO,
propriétaire, Jo Bling
- On attend des gros rabais, là,
même jusqu'à... ça peut aller
jusqu'à 70-80 %.
- Et pour attirer la clientèle
au Boxing Day, les experts
enenenenent pour dire que
les commerçants devront offrir
des rabais plus musclés
cette année.
Ici Jean-Philip